de cumplir 20 años y a causa de la
pandemia les resulta imposible presentar
su colección de fin de año ante un
público
apadrinada por yusuf of anna el creador
de la marca parisina es autobús la
tercera promoción de la escuela de moda
alternativa casa 93 se sube al escenario
en una película la casa es gratuita no
es necesario tener un diploma preconiza
la igualdad de oportunidades y enseña el
app cycling el arte de hacer algo nuevo
con lo viejo actualmente es cortejada
por el mundo del lujo que necesita pulir
su imagen y realiza colaboraciones sin
turistas parís se convirtió en un
desierto el boulevard haussmann centro
del consumo de productos de moda espanta
pero esta situación no desanima a las
galerías lafayette que le destinaron a
la casa una inmensa esquina en el piso
más lujoso del almacén
la mayoría de las personas se sorprenden
al saber que en realidad fueron los
estudiantes quienes hicieron esto en tan
solo un año como de todas maneras de
prejuicios muy fuertes en la moda esto
es muy pertinente aquí en este universo
silencioso pero acogedor estas prendas
no están a la venta es una operación de
seducción para sensibilizar al público
ante los beneficios de la moda
sostenible para nosotros en todo caso no
se trata de pensar si hay o no que
hacerlo es que ya no tendremos la opción
es absolutamente necesario involucrarse
en este tipo de iniciativas pero hay que
hacerlo con humildad porque la moda no
se cambia en un mes o en un año también
es necesario ser capaces de explicar que
esto pasa por etapas es una transición
aunque las prendas parecen exuberantes
incluso un poco desordenadas esto no
significa que no hayan sido concebidas
bajo la mayor reflexión es un atuendo
que se compone de dos piezas además de
los accesorios de cuero es un vestido
holgado y con la misma tela hice un
durán que bordea a mano que se ve por
detrás en fin me parece que al ponerse
este vestido uno se siente más
quiero que las personas se sientan mejor
con eso es una cuestión de aspecto el
dura la cola del vestido todo eso es una
prenda un poco como una armadura mental
el duda es a pañoleta que se convirtió
en el accesorio de moda imprescindible
de las estrellas de rap luigi la utiliza
de todas las maneras posibles esta pieza
en realidad salió de una cortina una
cortina que recuperamos en la casa 93
para eso quisimos integrarle varios
bolsillos un poco por todas partes un
collar bolsillo un bolsillo sujetador y
el bolsillo en la cintura junto a los
muslos también queríamos que fuera algo
con lo que se pudiera bailar fácilmente
el origen de la historia nadine gonzález
estilista creo en río una escuela de
moda gratuita para los jóvenes de las
favelas con el fin de permitirles
acceder al mercado laboral
ese fue el modelo que adaptó para
francia es una cartera prácticamente
reciclada porque la inicia con una malla
de construcción que recogí de la calle y
la recorte con la forma que me convenía
y luego recuperé tirones de cuero que ya
habíamos utilizado en otros eventos
en la moda siempre hay demasiado
desperdicio a pesar de que muchas cosas
pueden reutilizarse y nos puede servir
en la vida cotidiana
yo realmente quería hacer un gran
trabajo de bordado es decir personalizar
las piezas porque eso también es hacer
fighting y les añadía estas pequeñas
cadenas y estos pequeños ojales
quebrados con el fin de darle un poco de
movimiento a la figura
[Música]
a los distribuidores también les
interesa la casa mecenas de la escuela
le pidió a los alumnos que revisaran sus
archivos a partir de sus remanentes
yo trabajé sobre los años 50 entonces
realmente quería obtener esa cintura
marcada y esa falda bastante voluminosa
que recordar un poco un nuevo look de
christian dior por eso pensé que lo
mejor sería ser una crin o lina y
hacerla yo misma para aprender yo escogí
el tema 2030 porque me parecía muy
interesante imaginar el futuro creé mi
propia chaqueta con los envoltorios de
todo lo que no se había vendido del agua
dulce utilice un suéter que recorte me
gusta mucho el efecto transparente que
le añadió realmente se pueden ver todos
los envoltorios que hay en el interior
además eso hace que por dentro sea suave
porque son suéter
otro padrino louis vuitton le propuso a
los estudiantes imaginar un objeto que
encarnará una función ambiental y fuera
socialmente responsable así nació un
anillo anti veneno para permitirle a las
jóvenes detectar posibles drogas
vertidas en sus bebidas durante las
noches de fiesta el anillo existe pero
desafortunadamente no el antídoto
también surgió un poncho con múltiples
bolsillos atractivo porque está lleno de
objetos recuperados un estuche evocativo
perfumado con un aroma íntimo para
luchar contra las crisis de ansiedad y
que ocurre con los exalumnos al salir de
la casa 93 catar la uci continuó con sus
proyectos personales en el diseño de
prendas la danza y la fotografía y luego
fue contactada por la cadena cubrir para
crear una colección cápsula para la
marca sanción
el colectivo es algo que hace parte del
futuro y que debe hacer parte de él hay
que pensar que es necesario dejar de
hacer todo de manera superficial hay que
hablar sobre las cosas a profundidad es
no sólo vender sueños sino animar a los
jóvenes a que actúen por ellos mismos a
que digan lo que piensan
e inspirar a los jóvenes es darles poder
por ejemplo yo recibí comentarios sobre
mi proyecto con champagne y las personas
me dijeron nos inspiras estamos
orgullosos tan solo de ver que alguien
una joven así haya llegado hasta donde
quería llegar eso también nos da fuerza
y es también así como podemos actuar
sobre nuestro entorno y hacer algo por
el mundo
qatar la ufi tiene 21 años para ella y
para nosotros el mundo de mañana es el
de hoy
[Música]